I know it's been a while since you took
the uniform off but surely you remember
what it's like to be on the ground in
here or maybe your fancy suit affects
your memory
Orange is the New Black Star Brad
William Hankey has died he was 56 years
old the actor's rep confirmed the news
to ET on Thursday though no cause of
death has been revealed Brad is best
remembered for playing corrections
officer Desi piscatella on the hit
Netflix show
the best move is to let it die out they
don't know what they're doing
you don't know them like I do the role
earned him and his castmates a sag award
in 2017 for best ensemble in a comedy
series
it seems that somewhere along the way
everyone around here forgot the only
thing that matters your criminals and
you deserve nothing Brad also delivered
a memorable performance as coover
Bennett in the second season of
Justified well you could ask me
in my growing reefer
and I will tell you no
Brad starred in other films and TV shows
like Dexter October Road lost the
Chicago code the bridge speake Pete
Manhunt and the stand among countless
others this year he appeared in the
film's running gun and a block party and
when ETI caught up with Brad in 2020
amid the coronavirus pandemic to chat
about the stand he made sure to bring a
little cheer
Brad I'm loving the Christmas tree in
the background there buddy thank you
thank you very much I thought what do I
have that's interesting to put behind me
so there we go but before he began his
career in acting Brad played college
football at the University of Arizona in
1990 he played with the Denver Broncos
in Super Bowl 24 against the San
Francisco 49ers after suffering several
injuries during his NFL career Brad
retired in 1994 and began pursuing a
career in Hollywood he is survived by
his wife Sonia as well as his stepson
his stepdaughter and a grandchild